hey guys Alexa right here and we're
going to open up this super amazing
Kingdom Hearts - Play Arts Kai action
figure it is the Halloweentown Sora
version we just got it and it will be
available publicly very soon so let's
check it out so that's the inside
alright so here's our little man wow
he's like really really well done he
bends at the kind of knee not quite knee
and his arms Bend and his head moves he
stands on his own which is pretty nice
and he comes with all of these different
face pieces so this actually comes off
this little mask and he only has one eye
and a gaping hole where his other eye
should be so we're gonna fill that with
another mask and he comes with two key
blades the Kingdom key complete with the
little keychain of Mickey Mouse on the
ends and the Halloweentown Keyblade
which if you can look really closely
jack is on it and then his little dog
zero is right on the keychain which is
totally freaking cute and that is the
Kingdom Hearts Sora Halloweentown figure
it is coming out really soon you can
pre-order it or order it on the screen
next or online and I believe it's a
limited run so you're gonna want to get
them fairly soon so for more unboxing
videos of cool stuff coming out and be
sure to come back to GameSpot calm